louisa runs a lawn mowing business she
decides to measure the rate at which the
volume of fuel she uses
increases with the area of the lawn
what would be an appropriate unit for
louisa's purpose so let me let me reread
this to make sure i understand it she
decides to measure she's going to
measure
the rate
at which the volume
of fuel she uses
increases with the area of the lawn
so her unit should be something that
says volume
per area she wants to see how her volume
of fuel increases with the area of the
lawn so it should be volume
per
area should be her rate
so let's think about which of these
units give us volume per area
so
liters right over here that is
definitely volume
but this right over here isn't area this
is distance if it said square kilometers
or kilometers square then we'd be in
business so we could rule this one out
centimeters per kilometer well this is a
this is a distance per distance not a
volume per area so we can rule that out
centimeters per square kilometers well
this is a distance per area or distance
per distance squared but that is not
volume
per area so let's rule that one out
now liters per kilometer squared this
one's looking good this is a volume in
liters
and this right over here is an area and
this isn't the only one that would have
worked but this is out of the choices
this is the only one that works if they
gave if it was something like a
pint per
foot squared or a pint per square foot
or even if it was meter cubed per
per kilometers squared that would have
also been volume per area but this is
the best choice of these let's do
another one of these
snow is piling outside cameron's house
he decides to measure the rate at which
the height
the height
of the pile increases over time what
would be an appropriate unit for
cameron's purposes like always pause the
video and see if you can figure it out
on your own
so the rate at which height increases
over time so it should be a height per
time
or really i should say a distance per
time is what the height is going to be
doing the rate at which the height is
changing over time
it should be a distance or maybe even
better a length
length
per unit
time
so let's see this is hours per meter so
this is time per length this is the
reciprocal of that this one right over
here this is
time
per length as opposed to length per time
so i would rule that one out liters per
minute this is a volume per unit time
not a length per unit time rule that one
out
minutes per liter what is the time per
volume well we don't want to do a time
per volume we want a length per time
meters that's a length per time hour
that one works meters
per hour
this is a length
and that is a time
and it's good to always go back to the
original context he decides to measure
the rate at which the height of the pile
increases over time so if someone said
hey that height of that pile is
increasing five meters that would be too
much for a snow but let's say
it's increasing half a meter per hour
which even that would be quite fast but
half a meter per hour that makes sense
in your brain hey every hour i'm going
to get half a meter more of snow if i if
someone were to tell you hey the snow
outside is increasing at a rate of five
hours
is increasing at a rate of say five
liters per minute well that right there
that is that would that could be maybe
the volume of snow maybe over your
entire lawn or something but that would
not be giving you the height per time
this is height per time would be length
per time right over here